não sei então vamos continuar bom dia a
todos agradeço a terex me terem
convidado para estar presente
vou aproveitar para mostrar um exemplo
de uma pessoa surda eu sou surdo a minha
comunicação através de gestos se não vê
quando comunicação vocês não conseguem
perceber o que estou a dizer
por causa disso vem caindo testando
salvaria e deve ter um plano de
comunicação
joel foi falar aquela ponta feijoada vai
é preciso uma voz no entanto mesmo pra
dar pra comunicar com vocês é quando cai
não há comunicação
eu queria mostrar o meu programa dodô
que vou falar hoje tem quatro pontos
eu queria mostrar os 24 anos primeiro
novo vamos apresentar e explicar um
crime minha vida de uma forma resumida a
favor da liberação porque sou vice
presidente da da federação e pois vou
falar sobre o tema desconstruir e no
final queria que vocês fazem muito
carinho para fazer minha apresentação
eu sou surdo xia toda a minha vida ano
nunca tive só nunca houve nada x sem o
som já a x ouro e neste estudo profundo
irmão também é forno absurdos da minha
família e toda a minha família ouvindo
exatamente como vocês viajar estou já
estou com um irmão e isto que esta é a
minha língua mas já vamos ficar pertinho
da minha língua
agora vou fazer vou fazer 40 anos e
minha vida até agora a igual aconteceu
não sei nunca me sentia feliz por uma
versão não consegui trabalho
isto dói agora estou ingressar no
mestrado
ele nunca vai faltar online tenho minha
família os meus filhos têm dois filhos
que são 20 na mesma com eles para mim o
gestual os meus filhos sobre links e
minha casa já atuaram na escola quando
estou com os ouvintes falou da minha
vida até agora tem corrido tudo bem
vocês vêem e absurdo então como é que
vai resolver a vida deu na eu sei que há
pessoas que pessoas que têm algumas
dúvidas mas por isso aproveitei para
colocar um aproveito para ficar não
querem como é que é minha vida agora
quanto a federação
efe pa china interessada em conhece ela
é séria futebol
o objetivo é um ícone é o nível nacional
é pesquisas surdos ea federação trabalho
em colaboração com todas as associações
de portugal
todas as ea várias chances de subir
cerca de 30 a seleção trabalha com 11
anos conduzir as sessões
a federação tem que o objetivo é
proteger as pessoas da comunidade surda
ia melhorar o seu dia a dia
surda se tem algum problema barreiras a
fração tenta tratar e criar as
adaptações necessárias
a sessão está está integrada a a nível
nacional
no norte centro e sul
é a federação é importante mas já só vou
mostrar que é uma fração trabalhar
quanto é construído desconstruir mitos
não há perspectivas diferentes a
perspectiva da comunidade sobre a
perspectiva da comunidade ouvinte e nós
temos expectativas diferentes mas vamos
mostrar o quanto uma frase por exemplo
surgiu em uma frase tem uma idéia
somente tem outra por exemplo em
portugal
provérbio ficou bem é quando os
provérbios é o seu eu pensando como o
camisa 9 tv em provérbios
no entanto na na candidatura não há
sequer idéia do que são os provérbios
por exemplo os provérbios são ligados a
voz tão ligados de emoção
estou expulsão pela tv sobre o provérbio
e possui a cabeça agora não tem qualquer
forma visual nas missas frase a nossa
cultura no mais provérbios agora conta
piadas por exemplo avalia as pedras
jogadas são adaptações da voz os vêem
não quiserem não acham piada
estamos pedindo às diferentes agora eu
queria fazer uma pergunta
vários anos praticamente vamos buscá las
esse problema já comunidade ouvindo as
pessoas surdas tem a língua eu não tenho
língua você tem dúvida não é verdade
está em uma língua própria é o gestor é
uma língua é o visual tem um texto faz
parte da cultura dos surdos
vocês falam e têm noção mas nós não
temos solução então como é que nós
fazemos a nossa língua é através do
campo visual e quando chegam a uma coisa
por via oral inter trata de interpretar
e passar para o resto
linguagem acham que a linguagem ou
língua e linguagem pois linguagem não é
uma língua
os turcos têm gesto eu tenho já só tem
gramática tem se manca a expressão anjo
significado do gesto em portugal já foi
reconhecida em 1997 e foi aprovada como
língua oficial de surtos nos na escola
como é coxo ser uma informação através
do oeste da cidade
é verdade ou não na maioria diz que na
boa não é verdade
há várias línguas diferentes é como as
linhas gerais
cada país tem sua língua oral e nós
também e cada pessoa homossexual porque
porque devem estar ligada à cultura e
com cada peça uma cultura diferente a
língua também é diferente
é verdade ou não porque
confiar
sim em portugal a avaliar as palavras
são escritas mas a língua gestual não
acompanha a escrita é exatamente igual -
tornaram não lima já só acompanhou hoje
situado em frente tem uma gramática é
diferente por exemplo e fazer um gesto e
vocês que lá eu vou usar a gente possa
dizer que ela vamos ter agora é ficar lá
o que é isto
conduzir o carro
vamos dar outro gesto fez pressão
foi assim é carro se eu colocasse
pressão está ligada à vibração já é
conduzir
gostaria de completar vamos dar uma dica
por exemplo e 50
vocês percebem que teve 50 sim por causa
do dólar e teve essa opção
o que é é rápido e assim lembro sim
acham que eu vou acompanhar o português
a dar bicicleta não é fácil já percebem
que estão a andar de bicicleta
por causa disso é diferente da estrutura
quem tem de fazer esse trabalho é
interessante ele é verde com o benfica a
não deu certo e passar a mensagem não
tem trabalho a fazer isso ajudará a
trágica e estou aqui sinto mais leve
porque não tenho nem colocar o microfone
ao segurar e não fez nada disso deve ter
quem é difícil
minha senha palavra auditivo aparelho
auditivo
vocês conhecem é maioria das pessoas
quando chega uma certa idade começam a
ter perdas auditivas e qualcomm para ele
não é verdade
thomas de shorts acham que o aparelho
ajuda houve exatamente igual a muitos
ouvintes sim ou não usado não cresce
sim o aparelho é como uma ajuda para
ouvir o suficiente miami mas mesmo assim
vários chutes tenha para ele mas não
todos
por exemplo eu não tenho para eles
porque é que não tenho nenhum se nada
nada não vale a pena se eu fizer parece
que vai ser difícil sentir a vibração só
o que estão dizendo não faz ideia mas a
faixa mas há assuntos que tenham
aparelhos que conseguem conseguem ver
outros não mas é as pessoas que eu venho
pra esse pessoal automaticamente que eu
imaginava
entender como é que se diz confiante
porque
o
os fundos confiados quando técnica só de
barreira ou ouvinte acção desconfiados
susto estiverem num em grupo a comunicar
pelo gestual 521 charlson família estou
faminto a maioria van gaal próxima cacs
maria o vencedor que é que eu precise
macacos
eu conheci na imaginação de morte
vocês ouvem e vêem de mandarim ou em mão
e acham que é esquisito não é não é
português de vocês é pra igual a nós em
outra língua mãe na curva 9 30 às vezes
vem a não é portugal não é português
o ipgg que então a língua gestual hoje
em portugal sofria diz nuno graça porque
as pessoas vêem a português sim sou
português porque tua voz roger em frente
enquanto haja a comunicar isso acho que
você desse lugar em confusa
a questão é o reino dos surdos condições
de atuar
às vezes tem uma forma mais lenta outros
mais rápidas mas não quer dizer que
sejam olhados prever quando vocês falam
também você às vezes fala num tom mais
baixo diz paulo tom mais alto isso venha
é como se nós acreditássemos gritam
também hoje pronto já estuda uma forma
um pouco mais agressiva quando
estivessem não mais alto mas apesar de
sua situação
quando é com essa forma podemos ganhar
mas nunca dizer se que estamos zangados
alegada nossa expressão
andré
eu pergunto chu você já vem minha voz eu
sou muito fina
sim é verdade há muito tempo há muitos
anos atrás a comunidade surda havia o
choro do gestuário e assume
automaticamente que era um outro não
falavam ele não decidimos
atualmente não o conceito de muitos na
comunidade surda desapareceu não só
solto ou mudo
ele sempre foi ligado nas cordas vocais
o submundo não há palavras juntas numa
assunto e mudo porque o os outros podem
usar a voz mas um gesto comunicar não
sou muito novo chefe e não comunicam
qualquer forma são como as portas
no comunicado não fala nada
objetivamente não falam só mude mas a
opção não só têm uma língua única
através da língua não é muda
é verdade ou não não
todo show de gestão um final
e vamos conhecer dúvida a brascan em
portugal
não não são todos os shows costumam
algum gesto outros analisam porque serão
isolados de anos o isolado não é sozinho
isolado o nível linguístico porque a
comunicação não havia comunicação com
gestos teste só falava que chegam assim
então olha a lesão de weiss gestual e
seguem ou a estrutura da língua
portuguesa mas os surdos vem está dada
para comunicar mesmo que eu acompanhei
muito a língua portuguesa na nossa
estrutura gramatical mas a princípio não
é não é mesma língua propriamente nos da
pepsi
a maioria já estou assim uma minoria não
nos restou
10 álbuns algo mas lá todos os chutes
não dependo das pessoas tanto cada uma
no dia a dia o contacto que tem ea
própria pessoa é que a vai vai
conseguindo ou não e vai desenvolvendo
sozinha é a leitura labial
eu consigo consigo ler os lábios mas por
exemplo quando as pessoas têm bigode ou
tem muitas larvas e o barco para leitura
labial também tem como a pessoa fala a
expressão que faz xixi e eu consegui
perceber outras vezes não não consigo
mas na alma nós só o xoxa ouvinte também
consegue fazer leitura labial meus
filhos sou ouvinte e conseguem falar em
quatro anos e consegue analisar e fazer
leitura labial
às vezes eu falo e faço em só um sol só
faço
somente os lábios e eles conseguem
perceber ao principalmente que também
consegue perceber 8 do conselho foi
eleito pela via
é verdade
na se vocês gritarem o fórum é muito
alto a nossa mesma venha tentar através
da leitura labial comunicar outra vez me
quer mais falar mais alto não vale a
pena
a maioria das pessoas ganhar por aí acho
que os banheiros é é a estou a jogar bem
pra mim é porque você está falando alto
para as suas contas olhar pra mim não
tem de interagir de uma forma natural
nesta última os outros não conseguem
alcançar os objetivos vir as barreiras o
que vocês acham
falaram que minha profissão eu e sim na
escola e nas empresas as pessoas
trabalharem e eu sentia me um bom
trabalho também limpeza por exemplo a
não precisa da mãe
a maioria sem disfarçar não quer
arranjar algumas desculpas pra passar lá
e pensar por exemplo empresas da empresa
como é que vou comunicar no diaria a sua
décima casa feitas às empresas por outro
lado também é preciso algumas empresas
também têm segurado a pressão do sul
dizem não trabalharem
acontece que trabalha muito melhor que
os outros empregados e por quê porque
surda estava está focado está
concentrada no que está fazendo os
ouvintes trás
estreia-se na conversa é verdade então
tomar café é bom fora muito tempo
isso não tem nada a ver estão focados no
trabalho dele e pronto
persona vem realmente acho que trabalham
bem só mais uma vez para trabalhar na
nossa estrela gestuário ainda trabalhava
muito na água mas a mãe na maioria das
pessoas que sentem khan é preciso também
ter uma uma capa seria o sistema que
precisa visual maior obsessão visual
maior e concentrou-se mais a nível
pessoal eu queria falar um carinho
não sei quanto é que tem organização
quanto tempo o processo da juventude
estava um exemplo muito tempo em várias
rádios são expressas as pessoas abrirem
os olhos quando chamou participar que o
ok tudo bem então estou aqui presentes e
um objetivo também agride não querem os
olhos
o objetivo principal é que todos vocês
ouvintes vejam absurda e eu tentei
compreender nunca enviar uma língua
enfrentem uma cultura diferente e câncer
incompreensível nesse sentido adaptarem
sou surda e queria ver o que é um
absurdo muitas vezes nem percebe muito
bem as suas barreiras num quem é que
crianças barreiras não sou eu com o
absurdo
são vocês enquanto 20 por exemplo quer
informação as finanças por exemplo
chegou a ok e eu já estou e vocês
ouvirem falar pra mim então não percebo
como já é uma direita é a minha língua
o problema é se eu queria que vocês
maioria dos surdos podem adaptar tentar
adaptar-se um caminho aos seus ouvintes
ea escrever
bradaram estar ao mesmo nível dos dos
ouvintes no entanto mas nunca aprovei
assim este nível e acaba sempre gostaram
que nem frisar por isso é que eu criei
quando vocês não me querem como
aconteceu surda tenta fazer mímica
cometer a vagar descrever o que é
absurda e não fujam tamanho há muitas
pessoas que não consegue andar com as
suas surgiu perto de informações ou
chame chame ele e as pessoas a maioria
acaba por fugir um caminho e não nos
parece que o tempo é curto
ilustração um cãozinho foi ficar na
internet mas quer ver é importante e que
estava que vocês vissem o filme e que
gostava que me dissessem que é que
sentem
é mais ou menos minutos
clica vissem o filme percebe como é que
62 s
levo
agora como é que vocês sentiram que
deixa a situação
viram as barreiras isso não fosse assim
agora vocês vêem e raramente houve
incentivo moeda é exatamente o nosso
objetivo chamamos as pessoas e elas não
deixa estará na emprestado vocês
pensarem christi ao contrário ao fim mas
só tem dois
duas frases não ficar em outra fiscal
nem por suas tropas não movem mas vocês
ouvintes podem aprender a língua gestual
e dá pra criar a igualdade
é importante que vocês tenham vontade de
aprender para a segunda
vocês podem prender várias línguas
empurrando pra vocês pra provar o
envolvimento pessoal além de aproveitar
o problema eo gestual
estou em negociação mas só das pessoas
surdas no gestual é também a publicar
entre a longe eu entro janel com
empresas nelas
obrigado a todos e obrigado o atleta